dans la jungle terrible jungle le lyon
n'est pas mort ce soir et non le lyon
n'est pas mort et s'il est ici c'est
qu'il n'était pas dans la jungle parce
que ici nous sommes à nogent le fait aux
portes de chartres dans le domaine de la
tanière qui est un zoo refuge
pédagogique qui permet d'explorer le
monde animal et surtout de les secourir
et de les remettre sur pied patrick
viola ce à l'origine de ce pari fou
m'attend pour m'expliquer que cette
longue aventure est loin d'être finie
nous n'ayons n'est pas demain ce soir à
oui
[Musique]
bonjour patrick bonjour bonjour le
cacatoès et tu pointes à voler on a
appris à dire bonjour aux gens ah
bonjour coco soient polis la tanière
c'est avant tout donc un refuge pour les
animaux pour les animaux qui n'ont plus
d'autre solution ils sont pas tous sauf
maltraités on redonne une vie hors norme
une histoire et un futur meilleur oui
parce que c'est ça c'est pas toujours de
la maltraitance parfois ya des gens qui
partent de bonnes intentions mais ça se
termine mal et là vous intervenez c'est
très rarement de la maltraitance active
c'est du monde du savoir faire c'est
l'amateurisme souvent et où le syndrome
de données sur l'on collectionne
collectionne les animaux croyant bien
faire pourquoi m'avoir donné rendez vous
ici auprès des cacatoès parce que ces
animaux que j'adore
on les rares bernadette qui est un rat
qui est vraiment alain couture et puis
mon coup de coeur
bleu
et ensuite
parce que bernadette c'est un oiseau
mais moins con à dire ah j'ai compris un
rat c'est bon ça le coffret ci dessous
de ma gueule
voici bernadette majorant sur l'âge et
un oui moi je suis assez choqué
bernadette qui nous vient dougherty
récemment elle avait six mois pour
partir en belgique dans le trafic
d'animaux malheureusement sauf que
aujourd'hui maintenant la non non c'est
encore un bébé puisque eva luise 91 ans
81 81 ans un perroquet des années 80
donc là elle est très gentille avec moi
parce qu'elle fait rire son bec juste
savoir que si l envie de serrer le mec
écoute mon doigt si moi j'essaye ça va
bien se passer une banque mais mignot
des conseils et mélodieuse des seuils à
des tiers il faut pas l'aventuré on va
faire pour voir qu'on a peur
je le connais mandela danger
nous allons à la rencontre de cannes et
les ruches you win qui ce qu'ils ont
vécu une bonne partie de leur vie dans
les laboratoires quand exactement
raisins secs karine tu es en train de
manger la nourriture des animaux
prévient dégâts aussi j'aime bien les
vingt sept mois river ou pas dit
d'accord donc cannelle à la donne et où
il a pris plutôt sa vie pendant 19 ans
elle a travaillé sur la maladie
d'alzheimer et la magie de parkinson
comme beaucoup de ceux qui sont ici
voilà on se dit simplement nous qu'elle
a encore une quinzaine d'avions vivre si
on ne doit pas une retraite qu'est ce
qu'on fait sur terre donc en fait ça ça
redonne de l'espoir aux animaux oui on
dit toujours que c'est le premier jour
du reste de leur vie le premier jour du
reste de leur vie et c'est aussi le
premier quiz on va se quitter avec un
quiz monsieur je sais que vous êtes fan
de musique on se quitte dans la joie et
la bonne humeur avec patrick et violence
à ces partis et motivant non non pas de
la mort d'homme du passé ma jeunesse et
françois valéry françois déry bonne
réponse attention des sages vous pouvez
participer les divas du dancing
1986 philippe cataldo en tri en amont
bonne réponse cannelle votre réponse
vous avez vu y'a pas que les perroquets
qui parle hein ces salles est à dire